is
and i just think it's very things
actual
latest
okay
well they put that on last night
um
um
yes
75 percent
okay
oh
um
i
they don't want them
this
all
is
i feel like
potatoes
okay
all right
yes
everything's sticky
is
uh
is
hi everyone happy friday
all right um so today it's jobs day uh
we have our special guest
nec director brian diese joining us who
will give us an overview
and then take some of your questions
well i was going to say it's a sign of
the progress that we're making that the
last time that i came here the briefing
room was
significantly less full than it is right
now uh we are
making making progress across the board
and always except i guess now you guys
are
significantly more squished um so
uh so yeah happy to spend a couple of
minutes with you guys to just provide a
little bit more context
you all heard the president discussing
the
employment report that we got today so i
just want to provide a little bit of
additional context on how we
are looking at that data in the context
of
what we've seen over the course of the
last couple of weeks in the last week in
particular so
obviously a a strong and encouraging
jobs report today
850 000 jobs created last month
that takes us to more than three million
jobs uh
created uh since the president took
office
um under the hood on that i just want to
just raise a couple of issues
first is uh in addition to a strong job
story today we saw a strong
uh story uh about wages uh wages for
workers
average hourly earnings were up 3.6
percent uh over the year
uh and if you take out the pandemic some
of the some of the uh
movements in the pandemic that's we've
seen the largest three-month increase in
wages
um on record records go back to 2006.
and so
i think what we're seeing here is a
labor market where
as employers are increasingly
looking for employment and jobs are
plentiful they are paying higher wages
and people are taking
jobs at a faster clip good news on both
fronts
the second is as we look there's
obviously there's the payroll survey and
the household survey the household
survey is what feeds into the
unemployment rate
a couple of things under the hood in the
household survey that may
be of interest to you the first is
around labor force participation we
saw an increase in labor force
participation
among the prime age working populations
so
uh for those workers aged 25 to 54
we saw a an increase in and in the
pandemic
certainly because of the some particular
particularities around
uh uh teenagers and also early
retirements that prime age workforce uh
is particularly relevant and so we keep
an eye on that
uh the second is if you look at the
broader definitions of unemployment
which have been particularly something
that we and others have followed over
the course of this pandemic one notable
thing this
month is a marked decline in the number
of people who are working part-time for
economic reasons
so this is a category that the bureau of
labor statistics tracks where people
would like to be working more
like to be working more hours but are
only employed part-time
we saw a 644 000 person decline
in that uh figure over the course of
this past month again
a sign that those who are wanting to
work uh more are having an opportunity
uh to do so i would also note that there
was a um
a slight uh intake in the uptick in the
number of long-term unemployed that
number has come down
since the president took office but
that's an issue that is
is a reminder that we continue to have
uh challenges in the in
uh in an economy that is coming back
from a historic pandemic and we are
still down
uh more than six million jobs from where
we started so we still have a lot of
uh work left to do um
third point is just to put this report
in the context of a set of uh economic
data and indices we've seen over the
course the last week in particular it's
been a
a heavy week for economic data so just a
couple things i wanted to flag
um we saw consumer confidence come out
uh earlier this week
and not only did we see the index
increase for the fourth straight month
at very high levels now in terms of
consumers current and future sentiments
about the economy
but a record level of consumers are
seeing the job market as
improving so the in fact the the share
of consumers that say that jobs are
plentiful
in the economy is now at a 21-year high
so again consistent with a strong
recovering labor market here
we saw both the congressional budget
office and the imf
come up with come out this week with
updated growth projections
uh the cbo in particular doubled uh its
projected growth for 2021
from 3.7 to now 7.4
um and that's the if we if we achieve
that uh growth in that range it
would be the highest in nearly uh 40
years
but also notably the cbo not only
increased its growth projections but
projected downward where unemployment
will be
next year and also downwardly revised
its projections for 10-year deficits
so actually as growth its growth
estimates increased
its projections for future deficits as a
share of our economy came down
uh from where it was projecting uh in
february
uh likewise on the i uh on the imf front
uh projections of growth at seven
percent for the us economy
um in other words the fastest pace uh in
a generation
um also this week uh notably uh we
saw the oecd reach an agreement with 130
countries
endorsing a global minimum tax of at
least 15 percent
this has been a priority for president
biden in our
economic strategy from from the
beginning of this administration to try
to
help to galvanize a global effort to
actually end
the race to the bottom on taxes
and to encourage multinational companies
to invest and compete on
quality and price and not on the
effectiveness of being able to strip
profits into low tax jurisdictions
a historic um announcement uh this week
and an important milestone in our effort
to get that done
uh this um this year
um number four and i know and then i
will take your questions
uh is i just wanted to um also let you
know in terms of actions that we're
focused on to try to um
help address uh uh issues that consumers
are facing uh
increased competition uh and and lower
prices
i want to confirm uh that there was some
reporting this morning uh that the
president
um is indeed intending to direct the
department of transportation
to engage in a series of rule makings to
protect uh airline passengers and to
promote fair and competition
fair competition the airline industry um
this may uh sound esoteric but i'll make
it very uh simple particularly for any
of you who have flown or
are intending to fly now that the uh
that that's uh
more available the these rule makings
will specifically
uh ensure that if a passenger pays to
check a bag
they should get that fee back if the bag
doesn't uh
arrive on time also if the passenger
pays for
a service like wi-fi and it doesn't
actually work
that you will get that feedback
quickly and
uh and also uh the president will direct
d.o.t to
uh ensure uh uh rulemaking that will
um that will establish clearer upfront
disclosure of fees one of the uh
challenges and being able to clearly
understand baggage
fees change fees cancellation fees at
the time of the purchase of an airline
ticket so that consumers have
more and better information in
understanding what they actually
are paying for and that this
this direction will be part of a broader
effort uh that the
uh the president will release shortly
around driving greater competition
uh in the economy in service of uh lower
prices
uh for american families and higher
wages for american workers
so with that i'm happy to take your
questions with one caveat which you will
hear me say every time i come to talk
about
monthly employment data or anything else
which is
every piece of data is uncertain we
don't look uh we don't put too much
stock in any one month's
uh data we're looking at longer term
trends and certainly as we assess the
trend over the longer term
uh we feel like we are seeing a strong
uh
uh and and accelerating recovery uh
connected to
and driven by the president's economic
strategy
so good news on hiring but we saw an
increase
in black on the planet unemployment for
black men is about 10 percent
almost double what it is for white now
do you expect to close this gap in which
policies are going to be the most
important for getting that
well i'm glad you raised the issue and
certainly uh the
uh it underscores uh why
it's so important to uh not let up on
the
strategy that we've been putting in
place to drive a strong recovery
uh as fast as we can to get to full
employment
uh the one of the things that we know is
that
uh one of the most powerful ways of
actually addressing disparities within
the labor market and particularly the
persistent gap between uh unemployment
rates for
uh whites and uh people of color is to
have a strong
economy that is operating at full
employment where employers are
seeking to uh to have a wider scope and
and people who want to enter the labor
force want to find jobs have more
options and have more leverage and have
more power
in the labor market so you've heard the
president talk about this he
he went to cleveland and laid this out
in a speech that an explicit
part of his strategy is to have policies
in place to get us to full employment as
quickly as possible
i would note to your question about the
most important uh policies
um the american rescue plan uh was the
uh was unique
across the world in terms of fiscal
responses to this uh to this pandemic
crisis
the united states stepping in and having
a more aggressive fiscal response
than almost any country in the world and
what you've seen as a result is that
most independent projections pull
forward by a year or more their
projection of when we will get to that
full employment but as we assess what it
means to get to a full employment
economy
we believe it's it's critical to look at
that from an inclusive perspective and
not just look at the headline
unemployment rate and recognize
that these persistent
barriers uh that have driven those
uh those divergences in employment
outcomes
need to be at the center of what we're
trying to address and part of
what we want this economic recovery to
uh to achieve
oecd tax agreement are you concerned at
all that that could
get held up that the u.s could have
trouble enacting
part of that and also there were several
countries that um
are in the european union that didn't
sign on
is that going to be a stumbling block to
actually make it happen
so we see the announcement today
this week as both a historic milestone
and
really important momentum to actually
achieving both of the elements that you
said
momentum to enact a corporate tax reform
in the united states
that would not only help to improve u.s
competitiveness by
making it more attractive to invest here
in the united states rather than
investing in shifting production
and profits to low tax jurisdictions but
also raise revenue that we can invest
in productivity enhancing
measures like investing in universal
preschool along the lines the president
has laid out and in fact
the one of the principal arguments
against the kind of tax reform that the
president has laid out is
well if the united states acts what
happens if the rest of the world doesn't
come along well with this oecd
announcement we're actually
uh demonstrating that the world is
prepared to do that and and obviously it
connects to a set of constructive
conversations we're having with
leadership and the relevant committees
in congress right now about moving
forward the president's corporate
uh tax reform and this is a process uh
we
uh to your question about the the
remaining countries
this is a process we saw at the g7 there
were questions with the g7 come along
and endorse this framework and of course
they
did now we have the 130 countries uh
endorsing this framework and
we're going to keep working at it we're
not there this is a milestone in the
process but
seeing a real strong signal of momentum
toward the ultimate goal
hey brian brian what if you could
address that competition uh
initiative that you mentioned uh give us
a little bit more flavor of what's
coming on that
and then secondly i wonder if you could
address that uh the chip
shortage is still hurting uh ford for
example was down
27 in june um how much of a drag do you
think that's going to have
on on the otherwise rosy outlook you
just presented
sure so on the on the first i would say
i i won't i won't get ahead of the
president
you can anticipate the president's going
to be having more to say about this
shortly it's an issue that we've been
working on across the whole of
government
and the actions that i outlined with
respect to the department of
transportation is one element of it
but i think at the core just is is this
is really about
trying to uh impr uh to recognize that
actually
uh having more competition in more
competitive markets
is actually key to driving uh strong
durable shared economic growth and in
particular
we've seen increasing evidence that the
lack of competition in
a variety of markets can actually
reduce choices and increase prices for
consumers for small businesses and
actually
also hurt uh wages and wage growth for
uh workers
uh in in the labor market and so we're
looking at an effort across
the government uh looking at the
different anti-trust statutes and the
different measures that agencies can
take to try to
improve competition and actually improve
the opportunities for
businesses uh to compete fairly without
being impeded
as well so we'll have more to say about
that but that's the basic contours of it
um chips yeah yeah yeah so
so look um this has been an issue that
we've been you know focused on
uh for uh some time it was the focus of
the president's 100-day supply chain
review
and we've been in constant and close
contact with the auto manufacturers
consumer electronics producers and also
then the chip manufacturers themselves i
would say
in the short term uh i think we're we're
hearing signs of
there's some uh improvement uh in the
challenges
i think the second quarter clearly was a
uh
a point where you saw that uh impacting
uh both on the production side
and the employment side the we at least
the indications we're hearing from
uh from industry participants is that
you should expect some improvement
sequentially over the second half
of this year from our perspective on the
policy side it's why we're incredibly
focused you've seen the president laser
focused on
trying to move and enact his proposal
for 50 billion dollars to invest in
semiconductor
production manufacturing resilience here
in the united states that's the
long-term answer to this issue
and we've that's passed through the
senate um it's we're now working
uh uh with the house to try to advance
that legislation as well and
we look forward to getting that to the
president's desk as soon as possible
sorry um what are
just to go back to full employment what
are the metrics that the administration
will look to to determine when the us
has reached full employment
and then um on manufacturing why aren't
manufacturing jobs lagging so much of
only 15 000 in june still 480 000 below
pre-pandemic levels well i'll take i'll
take the second half of your
uh of your question first and obviously
um you can have a glass and maybe it's
half full maybe it's half empty but i
would say sequentially what we've seen
is progress in the manufacturing sector
both uh in terms of employment
um and uh and production and uh and it's
important to remember you know where
we're coming from we had a
a a pandemic and a historic economic
crisis that
uh that sent that that that cratered
uh production and uh and has has created
huge supply chain challenges in
bottlenecks over the course
over the course of the economy but i
think what we're seeing now is
demand has come back faster than
anticipated in large part because of the
success of the vaccination effort and
the historic fiscal response that the
united states
has taken and you're seeing
manufacturers uh respond and certainly
there's going to be some short-term
issues to work through
uh but but i think you know part of the
job growth that we saw in june uh is
reflective of the sector's
uh ability just uh to start coming back
um uh here and the first half here on
full employment
so look you know our approach is to
uh is to look at this from an inclusive
perspective
our approach has been to say what does
it mean to actually have an economy that
is working for
everybody and where workers who
who want an opportunity to be full
participants in the labor market
have that opportunity that means not
only looking
underneath the hood of the traditional
unemployment rate um at
the uh the the significant uh
discrepancies we've seen historically
uh uh on racial and ethnic lines but
also
on parents and women and what are the
barriers to full participation
in this economy and so you certainly see
that from the perspective of
the biden economic strategy to try to
invest in the drivers that are actually
going to
increase labor force participation
increase the productive capacity of the
economy by
having driving inclusive growth growth
shared growth the kind of growth that we
think will be durable across time
courtney this might have to be the last
one go ahead
right back here hi i wanted to ask you
about infrastructure and ongoing
negotiations on the hill
um the house passed its invest in
america act
i believe it was either last week or
this week and
house transportation chairman peter
defazio has said that he wants the
policy
in that bill to be how they flush out
the framework that the president agreed
on the bipartisan framework
is that something that you would agree
with is the policy in there what you
want
it looks like at the end of the day are
there certain policies you would want to
keep in the final bill
yeah so that was a that was a vote that
happened earlier this week and i i could
congratulate chairman defazio and
and uh the committee and uh and and
the house for progressing that this is
the process this is
you're seeing the legislative process
work you saw the senate
committee pass a surface transportation
reauthorization
unanimously out of committee uh with
chairman carper
ranking member capito um there and now
you've seen
uh a uh us a trans uh transportation
uh uh reauthorization pass out of the
house uh as well and uh as we've
said for some time the expectation is
that with the the legislative process
will
now work the way that it uh the way that
it has
and as part of the uh the bipartisan
infrastructure framework
uh moving from a framework agreement to
piece of legislation
as the president has said the uh the
committee chairman are going to be part
of that uh
process uh the the process is going is
is happening in the senate right now
uh but obviously uh working uh between
uh the uh the senate and the house is is
a key element of this so i think it's an
important milestone uh and uh chairman
defazio has shown extraordinary
leadership
on this issue and and we're gonna keep
uh working on it this is the legislative
process in real time uh working
working its will thank you brian so much
for joining us
he'll be back thank you all thank you
sorry go ahead all right um just two
quick items for all of you
at the top as we shared from the podium
a few weeks ago
of the white house recently established
the supply chain disruptions tax
task force co-chaired by the secretaries
of commerce transportation and
agriculture
to bring a whole of government approach
to addressing the near-term supply chain
bottlenecks
and supply constraints the task force
has been actively engaging with a broad
set of stakeholders
to diagnose problems and identify
solutions and we want to share a few
examples of recent
engagements given this is of great
interest alex asked about it just a few
minutes ago
or a version of it on home building
secretary romando and senator senior
commerce officials have been meeting
with timber
and logging companies sawmill operators
retailers appliance makers and home
builders from across the nation
and will meet in the coming days with
affordable housing and labor leaders
to ensure the challenges in the home
building supply chain are thoroughly
understood from every angle to address
bottlenecks in the sector on
semiconductors which affects
many industries including everything
from autos to everyday electronics
around our homes secretary raimondo has
continued to bring together
semiconductor producers
and users to build trust improve
transparency and facilitate data sharing
since march the commerce department has
supported nearly 75 billion dollars in
direct investments
from both u.s and foreign businesses and
domestic semiconductor manufacturing
and as for the department of
transportation under secretary budo
judge's leadership
the agency is helping address the
country's truck driver shortages
by supporting state dmvs as they return
or even exceed
pre-pandemic commercial drivers license
issuance rates in 2021
an average of 50 000 commercial drivers
licenses have been issued each month
which is 14 higher than the 2019 monthly
average and 60
higher than the 2020 monthly average uh
so clearly uh their work is ongoing
but wanted to provide you a bit of an
update about their outreach finally in
vaccine sharing news on sunday
we uh we annette we will send this
sunday we will send
1.5 million doses of modern uh to el
salvador sorry i will do the week ahead
um now as we look to the week ahead
which of course concludes this weekend
because the president has a busy
schedule on saturday
he will travel to traverse city michigan
with governor
gretchen whitmer is part of the
administration's nationwide america's
back together tour
to celebrate our country's progress
against the virus while there he will
visit a cherry farm
where he will highlight the benefits of
the bipartisan infrastructure framework
and what they will do to deliver to
communities across what it will do to
deliver to communities across the
country
after his visit to traverse city he will
travel to wilmington delaware while he
will
remain overnight on sunday the president
and the first lady will return to the
white house where they will host a
fourth of july barbecue
with essential workers and military
families on the south lawn
at 7 30 pm on sunday night the president
will deliver remarks to celebrate
independence day and independence from
covet 19.
and later that night the national mall
will be open for the traditional
independence day fireworks
display so friends and family can gather
together to celebrate our independence
from the virus on monday the president
will not have public events it is a
federal holiday and
next week we will have more details
hopefully in the coming days
uh but he will continue to amplify the
benefits of the bipartisan
infrastructure framework
the american family's plan and again
we'll have more announcements about in
the coming days
last thing um emily many of you know
she's gonna get embarrassed
um is a part of our amazing press team
she is a spokesperson on economic issues
not an easy thing so she's here hasn't
been in the briefing room today so i
wanted to welcome her here
and thank her for all her work and also
to chairman schiff who let me steal her
from him uh which i'm very grateful for
every day so just wanted you to all know
emily if you don't already know emily
josh go ahead josh definitely knows
emily yes
uh given last night's announcement on
holding federal executions
is the president satisfied with the
moratorium as it stands or does he want
to go further
and does he believe that justice
department lawyers should continue to
seek the death penalty in cases or
should they hold off
well i will first say josh that the
president made clear even during his
first conversations with then judge
garland about the job
that uh he wanted to see an end to
executions
and the announcement that was made today
uh is he's pleased to see that the
attorney general is taking
steps forward which will put a stop to
executions at the federal level during
this review
and that is what's ongoing and he feels
that's an important forward
in delivering on that discussion and
then secondly
with regard to the president
and sexual assault cases uh and kind of
where they are in the military chain of
command the president stopped short of
where senator gillibrand is
on having independent prosecutors
handled felonies to call for more than a
year in prison
what is the white house is thinking on
kind of the decision
relative to that proposal well first i
would note that we put out a statement
from the president and let me just
highlight
some some components of that for all of
you because this is an important step
forward
in his view today he strongly supports
secretary austin's announcement that he
is accepting the core recommendations
put forward by the independent
review commission on military sexual
assault uh he
views sexual assault as an abusive power
an affront to our shared humanity
and sexual assault in the military is
doubly damaging
in his view as it also shreds the unity
and cohesion that is essential to a
functioning
u.s military into our national defense
he also noted um and just to answer your
question that he looks forward
to working with congress to implement
these necessary reforms
he's grateful for the leadership of
senator gillibrand
the work of senator ernst representative
speer and representative mullen who have
worked in strong bipartisan way to move
this forward
and certainly he feels that this
announcement and the decision by
secretary austin is a step forward go
ahead same two subjects
first to the death penalty um there had
been a campaign pledge
to introduce legislation to end the
federal death penalty is that
again i would say that the president
felt it was so important that it was a
part of his discussion
uh with the attorney general when he
interviewed him and talked to him about
the job
uh he is now the the attorney general
today announced
that there will be a halt in executions
while there's an important review and
the president feels that's an important
step forward
uh some advocates have called on him to
commute all
federal death penalty sentences that's
different than what the attorney general
did
has there been any discussion of doing
that there's a review that was just
announced i don't expect that we would
speak to that while it's ongoing and
then on the sexual assault
report um it found in part
i'm just going to quote here why chasm
between what senior leaders believe is
happening under their commands
and what junior enlisted service members
actually experience
as a result trust has been broken
between commanders and the service
members
it's a scathing vote of no confidence on
the predominantly male military
leadership
and i'm just curious in his discussions
of the secretary of defense or with
uh uniformed leaders if he the president
has talked to these guys at all
about the fact that this persists and is
now
called out in this report well he's
certainly spoken with secretary austin
about it he's spoken about publicly
about his concern about what he's seen
and the reports of sexual assaults in
the military that have uh
were happening of course long before he
became president
and he also called out in a statement
today i wanted to recognize the
experience of our service members who've
survived sexual assault
and the bravery of those who've shared
their stories with the world and
advocated for reform which is something
he felt was important to
note and and call out today i would also
note that
uh secretary austin in coming out and it
and
accepting these court recommendations is
taking an action step
to change and hopefully change uh the
course of what we've seen over the last
separate for several years something the
president certainly applauds and
supports but it's going to take it's at
least 2023 to get much of this
implemented and we've got a bill in the
senate that has 60 votes at least
bipartisan is there going to be a push
by him to say
yes let's do this it's another example
of bipartisan
cooperation that addresses this issue
he noted in his uh statement that he
looks forward to working with congress
to implement these necessary reforms
and to promote a work environment that
is free from sexual assault and
harassment for every one of our brave
service members
and yes it is also the military the
leadership in the military secretary
austin someone the president nominated
uh and uh works with on a daily basis
who who accepted these recommendations
and they need to be implemented that
will take some time but that's a forward
step that was taken by our own military
go ahead
first of housekeeping if i can quickly
that we saw all the debris when we
arrived here at the white house earlier
today the president first lady were back
at the white house when the tornado
warning was in effect yesterday
where did the president first lady
shelter during the tornado work
uh that's a great question i they were i
don't know if they were back from their
trip yet or they were arriving shortly
back from their trip they were here at
the white house i don't have any more
details on
whether they were moved
let me ask you as we head into july 4th
very quickly obviously the white house
has said repeatedly that shots are safe
they're effective they're
available but obviously many states with
the lowest fashion
vaccination rates are governed by
republicans
right now what risk does the white house
believe those pockets
of non-compliance might pose to
other americans to the rest of the
country right now well i think the
guidance from medical experts is very
clear if you're vaccinated
you're safe if you're not vaccinated
you're at risk of getting the virus
and the delta variant the
transmissibility of it which we've seen
from medical experts
who have made clear that it is far more
transmissible
it can be deadly it can make people
incredibly sick it's just a reminder of
what risks people are putting on
themselves if they don't get vaccinated
so for clarity though what risks to my
question what risk do you think
those pockets of non-compliance pose not
just to themselves
but to the rest of the i wouldn't look
at it as pockets peter i would look at
it as
individuals in those pockets who are not
vaccinated are certainly at a
significant risk given the
transmissibility of the delta variant
but you don't think that risk is larger
than those individuals if individuals
are vaccinated in those areas then they
are protected
we have seen also had some news this
morning about the effectiveness of j j
but also we know that modern and pfizer
are effective
in fighting and protecting individuals
from the delta
variant i'd also note that we announced
just yesterday
our plans for a surge team largely in
response to the rise of the delta
variant across the country that will
include the physical deployment of
personnel
virtual assistants direct sharing of
resources we've already deployed this uh
a team to colorado to collaborate with
the local department of health in mesa
county
and that's something we will continue to
work with communities across the country
to implement to address the
rising uh threat of the delta variant
and given the white house is going to
fall shy of its 70
goal for at least one shot in the arms
of adults right now is the white house
done setting goals will you continue to
do that or do you think that there's
no longer effective well first that's
one way of describing it another way of
describing it is that we are
uh on track uh once the data comes in to
ensure to
report that 70 of adults 27 and older
have received at least one dose of the
vaccine that's a significant step
forward something we're incredibly proud
of
it's a reflection of the leadership of
the president of the
organizational expertise of the team
he's hired
and that's an enormous step forward
that's also why deaths and
hospitalizations have fallen by more
than 90
since january we feel it's important to
set bold ambitious goals
even though we are on track to reach
that goal for individuals 27 and up
our job is not done the work continues
even on july 5th
will we set a new goal is there a new
goal at your target i have no new goal
to set today
but uh again uh we feel that it's
important to set bold and ambitious
markers
uh and hold ourselves to account go
ahead and say jen is the white house
concerned that some
vice presidential staffers reportedly
feel like they work in a quote
abusive environment well i would first
note that i try not to speak to or
engage on
anonymous reports or anonymous sources i
will say that
the vice president is incredibly
important partner to the president of
the united states
she has a challenging job a hard job and
she has a great supportive team
of people around her uh but other than
that i'm not gonna have any more
comments on those reports okay
hoping to clarify the administration's
position here on defunding the police
you say
the president does not want to defund
the police is the president concerned
then that last year the now associate
attorney general vanita gupta said it
was quote
critical for state and local leaders to
heed calls from black lives matter and
movement for black lives
activists to decrease police budgets
well let me first say that as a fox news
report uh that came about in february
quoted
uh quote current former police chiefs in
more than 53 cities across the country
as well as the national fraternal order
of police
are issuing their support of the
nomination of vanita gupta president
biden's nominee for associate attorney
general praising her leadership
and record and urging the senate
judiciary committee to quickly confirm
her to the post
i don't know that that was your report
or not but it was certainly one from
your network but
she said okay so that's the fox report
thank you uh
and senate testimony she said she wanted
to decrease police budgets so
she also made explicitly clear in her
confirmation process that she opposes
defunding the police and the president
ran on most importantly
did not run on defending the police he's
always opposed defunding the police
i'll also note because you've asked this
question before or a few times over the
last several days
that when we talk about individuals
in congress and their support for
funding or
opposition to funding for the police i
think what the american people are most
focused on is how people vote
what their record is which is a public
record and i will note that
while the president ran on and won the
most votes of any candidate in history
and a platform of boosting funding for
law enforcement
after republicans spent decades trying
to cut the cops program
which again is public record we don't
need to uh under
under uh undervalue the intelligence of
the american people
the president ran on increasing that
funding it's in his budget
it was in president trump's budget he
significantly
cut that so that's a change and the
american rescue plan
had a great deal of funding for local
and state authorities
something that can support funding for
local police and communities across the
country
something many views doesn't require me
telling you names of individuals who
oppose the american rescue plan every
republican opposed the american rescue
plan
and i don't have time to read out all
their names today okay on another
subject the official white house account
tweeted yesterday
the cost of a fourth of july cookout is
down 16 cents
from last year
there has been a reduction in some of
the costs of key components of the
fourth of july
fourth of july barbecue that was what
the tweet was noting so does the white
house think
that 16 cents off a barbecue has more of
an impact on people's lives
than gas being a dollar more this time
i would say if you don't like hot dogs
you may not care of the reduction of
costs
you don't have to like hot dogs
i will say that what we are most focused
on is the fact that we've created now
more than three million jobs since the
president took office that's we're
focused on
and continuing to implement additional
uh components of his economic build back
better agenda go ahead
andrea just kind of switch gears great
hot dogs so uh the
uh president of belarus has shut the
border to ukraine
you've expressed concern about those
culture travel can you give us an update
on what's happening there and what your
reaction is to that and
is it time to to take more serious
action as you know
we have put in place a number of
sanctions over the past several weeks in
coordination with our european partners
um i had not seen that report before i
came out here i will uh talk with our
national security team and see if
there's any additional actions or calls
that are happening today
and then um on the international front
these oecd
talks are now going to be heading into
the g10 at gemservg20
meeting that's coming up the treasury
secretary will be going
can you just from where you said sort of
say what your primary
you know goal is for this upcoming g20
meeting on the finance officials and
what you were sort of you know what the
president is saying to to the treasury
secretary but what would you like just
to get done
well i i would say obviously the
treasury team and the treasury secretary
will preview
what the focus of their trip is as you
know and as you asked
uh my colleague brian dies about
certainly a component of that will be
about the global minimum tax
uh and moving that across the finish
line i will note and he touched on this
a bit but
we are quite encouraged and it is a
positive sign in our view
that there are 130 countries
representing more than 90
of global gdp uh who have come together
to support
the biden administration plan for a
strong global minimum
tax um and of course there's more work
to be done
uh but that is will be certainly a focus
but otherwise i would
defer to the treasury department i'm
previewing the secretary's trip the
president is going to be speaking later
on today to the national education
association
um what is his primary concern and you
know we've talked a lot in here about
critical race theory is this something
that he's going to bring up in terms of
the teaching of american history
well i would say first he's married to a
teacher um
and a long time teacher still a teacher
um and so certainly
educators and making sure he is
communicating conveying his commitment
to
the education system and the role of
educators in the country is always going
to be close to his heart
i will certainly expect that he will
talk a bit about his plans and
initiatives whether it's the american
jobs plan or the components of the
american families plan which will be
critical to uh communities to school
communities across the country
um but i think that would be the focus
of his remarks go ahead on afghanistan
the president said earlier he does not
think the drawdown will be done in a few
days
the pentagon has said it's ahead of
schedule the september 11th date so what
is the latest
date that the white house is looking at
right now uh well we currently expect
it to be completed by the end of august
uh so as you know the president
uh decided to withdraw remaining those
troops from afghanistan and finally
end the u.s war there after 20 years i
know there's been some reporting about
bagram which i expect it may already be
out
there'll be a statement from the
secretary of defense on that
sometime today but in terms of the
timeline
we currently expect it to be completed
by the end of august okay and when it
comes to the translators
that have applied not just translators
drivers engineers people who really put
their lives on the line
for the us that are waiting on these
applications is it true that the
administration is considering housing
them
in central asia several countries in
central asia while they wait for those
applications
to either be accepted or denied there
have been some reports about
conversations i'm not here to
confirm any conversations what i can
tell you is
uh we've identified a group of siv
applicants who have served as
interpreters translators
as well as other as well as other
at-risk categories
they will be relocated to a location
outside of afghanistan there are a range
of options
uh and that will happen before we
complete our military
drawdown by the end of august um in
order to complete their visa application
process from there in terms of
locations or numbers i'm just not going
to be able to get into those specifics
for security reasons and can you explain
why the president was citing the july
4th weekend when he was being asked
questions about afghanistan as to why he
did not want to answer further questions
on that matter i think what he was
trying to convey to all of you
is that he is heading into july 4th
weekend a weekend for family a weekend
to celebrate america
and um that he was uh ready to be done
answering questions it wasn't uh it
wasn't related to
afghanistan on was that the fighting is
of the things that he sort of
getting closer and closer to kabul
if the afghan government falls if there
is a bloodbath in kabul
is there any circumstance where the u.s
is reconsidering is thinking about
cutting troops back
i think it's really important to
remember what the president conveyed
when he made his announcement or how we
kind of got to this point
uh first when he announced our drawdown
he made clear
that the taliban would have been
shooting at u.s troops again after may
first
and the withdal dewalt with the
withdrawal deadline negotiated
by the previous administration kind of
set that timeline
also when he came into office with the
lowest number of u.s and partner forces
in afghanistan since the early days of
the war
an agreement as i know it just noted was
already in place uh
and the military stalemate between the
taliban and afghan forces
was at a height um he also asked for a
review of genuine
realistic options to advance and protect
us interests
the review did not sugarcoat what the
likely outcomes would be
or rely on best case scenarios and we
were emerged from that with a clear-eyed
assessment of the best path forward to
advance american interests
which is his focus and his role as the
commander-in-chief and the president of
the united states
and ending the war in afghanistan after
20 years
so that we can address the global threat
picture so that we can protect our men
and women serving
was his priority so uh that continues to
be and he continues to
uh we're continuing to move forward
toward our withdrawal plan by the end of
august
that's what you said yesterday you were
asked about the end of the supreme court
term
you reiterated the president's bit
should there be an opening to
nominate an african-american woman he
said a year ago that he was creating a
list that he would uh release that list
for further vetting
can you tell us what the status is is
there going to be a list of potential
nominees
that's released for us to see well there
is not an opening on the supreme court
um so that's not a current hypothetical
we're even dealing with right now uh he
made clear at the time or maybe around
that time
that he would nominate an
african-american woman to serve on the
supreme court should there be an opening
while he's president and he remains
committed to that uh
to that should there be an opening go
ahead david
jen uh about a little more than a week
ago
the agreement with the iranians to allow
inspections to continue
at um uh the main sites expired
and a couple of uh administration
officials including i think the
secretary of state had said that
it would be a big problem if we lose
inspection continuity
so now we're a week out is it your
understanding that
we have no inspection continuity and
tell us how this affects the way the
president is hoping
that all this will unwind how do you
actually get to an
agreement if you're not sure that things
have been diverted along
well i think we certainly expect there
could be challenges on the road to
getting an agreement and we've lived
through a version of this before as of
you uh
i will say that uh consistent with what
the secretary of state said
uh we believe iran must comply with the
iaea's inspectors and it must comply
with its obligations under its
safeguards agreements with the iaea
we're working with allies and partners
to reinforce broad support
for the iaea and the director general as
he and his team carry out
their important work and certainly our
message
has continued to has been from the
beginning but i will reiterate
that one of the reasons to move forward
and to continue to pursue a diplomatic
agreement
uh to re-engage with our partners p5
plus one partners and the iranians even
indirectly
is because we want to have that reliable
access and understand and have
visibility
uh into what the iranians are up to and
how close they are to acquiring a
nuclear weapon
obviously we've just concluded the sixth
round of talks
everyone's back at their capitals i
don't have anything to preview for you
in terms of
next round but that certainly is our
hope in terms of the next step
just following on the question you got
before in afghanistan
when i asked president during that
previous event on the economy
about kabul he said we've worked out an
over the horizon capacity that we can be
value-added
but the afghans are going to have to do
it themselves with the air force
they have so if we just understand
what he said and then your answer before
to caitlin
is he essentially saying if kabul falls
it is not our primary responsibility at
this point we're happy to go help
but it's completely up to you he's
saying that as we said in the beginning
he asked for a review and an assessment
of what the impact could be
of our decision to withdraw troops we
asked them not to sugarcoat that they
didn't there has been intel assessments
that have been out there from our own
government
we're certainly aware of those we have
never taken a step back from those from
the podium or from the president of the
united states
at the same time what i think he was
conveying during his answer to you david
is that we will also continue to work
collaboratively
as we always have with a range of
countries that share our interest in
countering the re-emergence of a serious
external plotting capability emanating
from afghanistan should that emerge
we will maintain over the horizon
capacity and we
that is something that will continue as
well as our security assistance to the
afghan
national security forces but they will
be in the lead as has always been the
plan when withdraw our troops
go ahead thanks jen uh terry richardson
the u.s track star
has been suspended following a positive
test for marijuana use
does the president support that penalty
or does he want to see her
be able to represent the united states
fully at the olympic games
i would say first that this was an
independent decision made by the u.s
anti-doping
agency and not a not a decision that
would be made by the u.s government as
is appropriate
and we will certainly leave them the
space in room to make their decisions
about
anti-doping policies that need to be
implemented i will also note
that um shikari richardson is an
inspiring
uh young woman uh who went has gone
through a lot personally
and i think uh and she's also happens to
be one of the fastest women in the world
and that's an important part of this
story as well so uh
this is an independent an independent
decision by the u.s anti-doping agency
but i also felt it was important to note
uh who she is in her history
today i follow up on afghanistan when it
comes to the uh vulnerable
afghan employees we're talking about
that could be moved to other countries
what assurances does the administration
have to them that they can be moved
safely that these visa applicants can be
moved safely isn't there a target now
on their backs now that the taliban
knows that they're you know potentially
going to be
well sean i think one of the reasons
that i'm not going to get into security
details about
what third country they might go to um
and how many
is exactly for that reason uh but
certainly our timeline is to
relocate these individuals to a location
outside of afghanistan before we
complete
our military drawdown i'd also note that
we will continue even after we have our
military
with drawdown with a presence in kabul
a diplomatic presence as well on the
ground there
but certainly that's the goal of our
timeline and the reason i'm not getting
into more specific details go ahead
two quick questions on voting rights um
one is actually a logistical question
sure he said yesterday that he intends
to
kind of tour around and go and speak on
this issue um
will he give remarks next we can get
embedded
sure um he is eager to do that as is
evident by his
uh mentioning it to you all yesterday
and over the last couple of weeks
um and i think as you would know
hopefully in his statement yesterday
he is profoundly disappointed by the
supreme court's decision
it's just a reminder of how important it
is to move forward on federal
legislation
uh how important it is to an urgent it
is that congress restored the voting
rights act and it's a reminder of
what the stakes are here which is that
our democracy is on the line
uh we as as i noted in the beginning we
are still working out and finalizing
details for next week so i just don't
have anything to preview in terms of
travel or the focus of this travel at
this point in time
another related question which was
actually on the remarks he gave
yesterday about the arizona voting
decision i just wanted to clarify
something so
he said it is mildly positive in the
sense that there's a remedy available
based on the particular voting decision
and oh canada i was just confused
i have to look more closely at the
specific uh statement
you know i think that um the president
views this issue broadly as one where
we need to continue to use every lever
at our disposal whether that is
actions taken by the department of
justice that the attorney general has
already announced
some of in the last few weeks or it is
efforts that we have underway led by our
vice president to
engage with civil rights groups state
legislators and the american people to
push back on anti-voter
laws at the state level um but uh that's
broadly what his view is and i think
what he was trying to project in this
statement go ahead jen
um openplus has been stuck in talks
around
raising oil production to ease prices is
the white house concerned about high oil
prices and has the president or anybody
in the administration been in touch with
allies in who are involved in opec
to talk about this and then somewhat
relatedly
um on on gas prices being high in the us
uh at you know peak travel time probably
even more so
because of kind of the pandemic getting
better
um you know are you concerned about that
for americans at a time when it does
seem like there are a lot of
economic data points working in your
favor that this one that
americans really do feel day in day out
um
it is it's not you know in a great
position
sure we'll generally first say that uh
there are of course
we have seen an increase in the price of
oil as anyone has seen as they've seen
as who watches data it will be of course
a topic of discussion as you noted uh
when opec meets
over the coming days i'm not in a
position to speak to those conversations
from here
i do i can say that currently we expect
there is enough spare oil
production capacity globally and as you
know because of the restart
of global economy and resumption of
normal consumer activity there is some
impact on oil market
conditions uh on your second part of
your question on the impact of
individuals and consumers
absolutely i mean that's one of the core
reasons why the president was opposed to
a gas tax
uh and was opposed to a any tax on
travel or vehicles uh vehicle mileage
because he felt that would fall on the
backs of americans who were returning to
their workplaces who were driving their
kids to school
and that was a bottom line or a red line
for him in the negotiations
as you know well uh the price of gas is
often linked of course to oil
prices that will again be a topic of
discussion over the coming days but i
don't have anything to preview on that
front
go ahead thanks jim um on the subject of
infrastructure
uh there are a number of republicans on
the hill who raised concerns about the
idea of
giving the irs 40 billion dollars to
basically crack out on check tax
decide a cheats of concern one of which
is that they think that this
this raises the possibility of abuse by
the irs
um i'm just wondering what the
administration's response to that is and
also how pivotal
is this rs component to paying for the
president's infrastructure plan
well first i think it's a key pay for
and one that was agreed to by a
bipartisan group who negotiated the deal
and for clarity what the what it
actually would do
is ensure that the irs has the support
the staffing
and the resources needed to ensure the
wealthiest americans are paying what
they owe
that's exactly what it would do we have
some estimates of what
that would raise in terms of pay fors
those are actually quite conservative
when you look at
what economists many economists suggest
across the board
uh but it is a paid for that was agreed
to and one that does not violate uh what
was a red line for many republicans
which was
in these bipartisan negotiations doing
anything to change the 2017
tax law we will of course go to that
when we go to reconciliation but that
was a
red line as it related to these
negotiations
go ahead jim we saw that the president
was exasperated
this morning when he was asked several
questions about afghanistan and bagram
bear with me for a second but 20 years
ago we were a nation full of
people most americans were gung-ho
full of patriotism to go get those
people who had attacked our country in
2001.
20 years on now where we seem to be
average americans are just shrugging
their shoulders
at the fate of afghanistan they may have
afghanistan fatigue does the president
feel that way does he have afghanistan
fatigue
does he sense that in the american
people first i would say that
the president has long felt as many
americans have and many leaders have
that the war in afghanistan was not one
that could be won militarily
that's why we have supported diplomatic
negotiations and discussions and we will
continue to be engaged in those moving
forward
and again we'll continue to have a
diplomatic presence on the ground
even after we bring our men and women
home as commander-in-chief
you have to make decisions about how to
protect the men and women serving
when when the may 1st deadline was set
that gave provided us a timeline in
which the president had to make a
decision about bringing our men and
women home or beginning that process
so that they did not risk greater
threats on the ground
he went through an entire review and
assessment by his
national security team to jump to that
conclusion and i will also reiterate
that we will continue
to provide security assistance
humanitarian assistance
and be partners to the government of
afghanistan in the months ahead as is
evident by the fact that he hosted
leaders here just last friday
does he do does he feel that way do you
think
i i would say i think people are a
little overreading into his response to
a series of
a q a uh leading into a holiday weekend
when he had already answered three
questions on afghanistan and he just
said
this is the fourth question and he then
went on and answered a couple additional
questions
the president could not be more proud of
the men and women serving who have
served over the last 20 years and he is
going to use every opportunity he can
to thank them for their service thank
the families of those
fallen service members who served
proudly and bravely in afghanistan
but this was a decision he made because
he felt it was in the best interest of
our national security in the united
states go ahead
oh okay i think you guys have together
okay go ahead you go last one all right
thank you
you mentioned that a kobe 19 surge team
was heading to colorado
do you have an update on when one could
be arriving in the state of missouri
and could you speak to the broader
concern that the administration might
have
about the midwest as a region and then i
do have one other question after that
sure
um let me see if i have i think i have
oh we are also working with uh closely
with missouri health department in
identifying needs there and we're
prepared to mobilize a team to missouri
where the focus is on vaccine confidence
efforts epidemiology surveillance and
sequencing support
related to the delta variant i would say
our concern is where there are
communities where there are lower
vaccination rates because it means more
people
are at risk and we are going to continue
to do everything
in the power of the federal government
whether that's providing supply whether
that is sending surge response teams
whether that is
ensuring people understand where they
can get access uh
or whether it's communicating directly
to young people people under 27 who have
a lower
vaccination rate that will continue in
communities in the midwest or
in any parts of the country where there
are lower vaccination rates
thank you have a great day and follow up
on the president's visit yesterday just
serve
side yeah once that investigation is
complete and we know
more about what caused the collapse is
there
legislation potentially uh would there
yes be supportive of federal legislation
that would address issues like building
standards and condo association
oversight and building recertification
let's see what the investigation
concludes and then we can have a
discussion about the next steps thanks
so much